ابدا معك فرح الزمان في انقره طبعا في هذه
الساعات الاولى من الاقتران عن نسب
الاقبال والجو العام للتصويت
مريم ان اردنا ان نقارن هذه الجوله
بالجوله الماضيه ونقارن بذات الساعات
استطيع ان اقول لك بان الحضور قد يبدو اقل
كثافه حتى الان ولعل هذا يرتبط بمساله
ثلاثه وسرعه العمليه الانتخابيه اذ يحضر
المشاركون او الناخبون الى مراكز الاقتراع
ويغادرها بسرعه الجوله الماضيه كانت تصويت
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه والانتخابات
البرلمانيه معا وهذا كان يؤثر زمنيا على
مساله عمليه الاقتراع لكن هذا الامر
يتزامن مع وجود دعوات للمشاركه اكثر في
هذه الانتخابات وذلك لان نسبه المشاركه
تؤثر كثيرا في الحقيقه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي مثلا يلحظ ان مناصري مرشح تحالف
الشعب كل جدار اوغلو يدعونا للقدوم
لصناديق الاقتراعي يخشى البعض من مقاطعه
له الانتخابات سواء بسبب خيبات من اداء
كلش دار اولو خلال الفتره الزمنيه بين
الجولتين او خيبات بسبب تحالفاته التي
اجراها او بسبب اعتبار بعضهم ان النتيجه
قد تكون محسومه اكثر لصالح مرشح تحالف
الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان على الجانب الاخر
دعوات ايضا لمناصري اردوغان للحضور الى
صناديق الاختراع ولتحقيق مشاركه اعلى من
الجوله الماضيه وعدم التراخي باعتبار انه
حقق تقدما على منافسه في الجوله الاولى
بالتالي هنالك الان اقبال لكنه اقل من من
ذات الساعه في الجوله الماضيه مريم ان
اردنا ان نركز اكثر على انقره ان كانت
اسطنبول تمثل الخزان الانتخابي سواء
سياسيا او من حيث عدد السكان نحن نتحدث
هنا عن العاصمه وعن مكان فيه رمزيه عاليه
في الحقيقه يحاول المرشحان ان يحصل في او
ان يفوز فيها لاسيما ان كل جدار اوغلو فاز
في العاصمه انقره خلال الجوله الماضيه رغم
ان الفارق يبلغ 52 الف صوت فقط لكنه تقدم
على منافسه اردوغان بنسبه واحد بالمئه
لذلك هنالك منافسه شرسه ومحتدمه بين
الشخصين هنا لان انقره تبقى هي العاصمه
وتمثل الرمزيه السياسيه ويسعى اردوغان
لانتزاعها من منافسه الذي فاز فيها في
الجوله الماضيه المشاركه او نسب المشاركه
ايضا مريم نحن امام 60 مليون ناخب في
تركيا ينضم اليهم انضم اليهم في هذه
الجوله اكثر من 47 الف ناخب بلغوا الثامنه
عشر خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين لذلك الكل
الان يدعو الى المشاركه التصريحات
السياسيه تتحدث سواء من الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات او من وزاره الداخليه التي
تؤمن هذه العمليه وقد شاهدنا تواجد
العناصر الامنيه والمراقبين بشكل مكثف في
الحقيقه في المراكز يتحدثون عن سير هذه
العمليه بثلاثه تصريحات ثانيه لوزير
الخارجيه التركي خلال ادلائه بصوته يتحدث
كذلك عن اهميه الديمقراطيه واهميه
المشاركه على طرف ثاني ميرا الاكشنر زعيمه
حزب الجيد وهي المعروفه
بمواقفها احيانا غير الراضيه حتى من طاوله
المعارضه ذاتها تتحدث عن ضروره الانتخاب
والوصول والوصول الى مستقبل جيد لتركيا
على حد